this all started in the beginning of
2015. so we met through mutual friends
he was really cute and outgoing and
um
oh sorry
we would take turns making drives um to
see each other and hang out and then
early on he told me he had chronic
kidney disease and crohn's disease so he
had to connect to a machine every night
to filter out his kidneys at that time
he was 27 and had it for 10 years just
knowing that his kidney function was
already below five percent it made me
have this urgency to help him i didn't
want to
wait to you know have his
condition get worse or he could have
passed away too
in order to donate you have to be in
good health they have to do tests to
make sure your body can survive with
just one kidney how stupid am i if i
just realize right now that there's more
than one kidney in there
it was funny i've had kidney stones
i don't even know
how many kidneys we got
two okay
now
she didn't give her one kidney
or one of three
there's a lot of people out there that
didn't even know what kidneys were they
thought oh kidney beans like
it's okay it's okay
and to be fair
oh like i said how many when this baby
said i'm about to give away one how are
you gonna survive with just one like
what did i assume that she's gonna give
up multiple yeah
i give my two three kidney i get one of
my mama i get one of my dad
you get a kidney you get a kidney we all
get kidneys you know what i mean so yeah
it's okay you're not the only one and to
be fair my dad's a nurse so i was always
in his books and [ __ ] so yeah i know
yeah
we only have one liver though right
you don't know that we have two livers
ah don't [ __ ] with me did you [ __ ] with
me yeah okay probably around three four
months uh going to his doctor getting
blood work done and a glucose test um
different types of scans and then in
november that's when i got the call the
doctors told me my body was ready to go
and i was ready for surgery
okay hypothetical
how soon
is too soon
to be giving your significant other your
kidney don't
don't
what you mean though
um
[Music]
you got kidney problems wow
i like wine bye
[Laughter]
and to be fair
i mean the reason he probably cheated on
you because you know
he could get another kidney
so i was the one who chose the date to
be may 23rd because 23 is my favorite
number i was born on december 23rd and
michael jordan is my favorite player so
so you see how all that [ __ ] don't work
you pick out your favorite number
jordan
this that the star was online it don't
mean [ __ ]
i was tempted to youtube the procedure
before just to see just to get an idea
what my body's gonna go through but
i didn't and i i'm glad i did
surgery was pretty easy they put me
under um anesthesia so i was knocked out
the whole time once i woke up i just
remember waking up to tubes in my mouth
and they tried to feed me
you know ice cubes and i almost threw up
but other than that i just went back to
sleep and
it took me about
two weeks to recover like to feel back
to normal so my doctor only recommended
me to not drink you know a lot i don't
drink a lot anyways so it wasn't really
a big sacrifice to me and to not do
physical sports like boxing and i was
totally okay with that
so for him his lifestyle changed they
took the tube out of his stomach so he
didn't have to go do dialysis anymore he
just had to take anti-rejection pills
and
pain medicine his family was really
grateful and they cried a lot it just
felt great for the both of us a few
months after the surgery my boyfriend
went to a bachelor party in vegas with
some of his christian friends um his
best friend was getting married hey man
listen when it comes to vegas that's
where christians go to be good
christians
he was texting me throughout the trip
how much he didn't want to be there
ah babe yeah
this is the worst trip ever i got
i don't want to be doing any of this i
just want to be home with you inside of
you
right now
wow so she was inside of him while she
was inside while he was inside someone
else
technically she's always inside of him
technically out here forever yes i can
see her being at the altar when he's
getting married somewhere else in black
till death do his part she'd be like
[ __ ] you still got my kidney though
she's gonna be part of you and i'm gonna
be part of me
what you just said made no sense
yes
but i'm gonna breeze past it until you
called me out
why did you just let that one go because
you never let some [ __ ] go whenever i
say some [ __ ] that's true okay but you
know the way to create a change is to be
the see see the change that you want to
see in the world huh
what did i say
just leave it there thing
be the change that you see in the world
what
you're calling your own you know what i
said [ __ ] you see the change be it
you make me think of that african dude
the african dude
do not
i
hey
don't judge they don't cover
the book
they
don't judge
don't do it
don't don't do it
you know what
in life
uh
don't cover the charge pipe
oh
don't judge the the
cover touch the hook iron man don't
don't put the cover
don't whatever don't do it just don't do
it
how much he just
wanted to read the bible and then i
responded to him like no just enjoy
yourself you know you don't really go to
vegas too often and
you know you're with your friends you
don't have to go under dialysis anymore
so
you know just have fun i didn't think um
anything was gonna happen in vegas
because he
portrayed himself as a really religious
man and he stuck through his morals
throughout the relationship
and so i thought this was just a regular
weekend on the sunday that he was coming
home he came to my house unannounced
panic in his eyes and just like pale
like he looked really scared and i was
just confused on what happened and then
that's when he admitted to the cheating
he
admitted to doing things with some of
the bachelorette party it's funny
because
those girls knew who i am and
i know one of them was a close friend to
mine too and i was
just
broken and then after he came and
confessed what he did
you know those girls are probably seeing
this circle like oh she gave him his
kidney well let me give him my [ __ ]
well i'll one-up you he can get my
[ __ ] no wow okay hey i'm just saying
that's a powerful girl thing
like if i do my [ __ ]
doesn't give a girl like or somebody i
know doesn't give a girl
his like
kidney or liver or anything like that
is she trying to
how about you foul ass
he's inside you right now
she's inside you
huh
what'd you say
what's your shot what are you talking
about
i'm talking about homie
if his girl was trying to get with me oh
after he gave her oh okay
triangle kidneys transfer yeah yeah yeah
yeah
that's foul yeah those women are foul
too yeah because you know generally if
you cheat and you're in a relationship
you cheat
i put all the blame on the person who
cheats
yeah not the person you cheated with no
but if the person they cheated with
knows everybody yeah and knows a liver
was here yeah you shady yeah you shady
yeah everybody's shady yeah everybody's
shady that's you
i had to go to work i had to go to work
at disneyland the happiest place on
earth i was scheduled to work at the
churro cart at pixar pier and i really
didn't want to cry in front of the
guests one of my co-workers knew
something was wrong and then he asked
are you okay and that triggered me just
the tears just
fell down my face and i just couldn't
stop crying and then
my lead let me go home for the night i
thought about it for a while and i
decided to try to make things work maybe
he deserved another chance maybe
we can work it out and make it
make it happen for us and
after everything that happened it
definitely hurt my trust issues with him
and
it was hard to trust again especially
when i thought he wouldn't do anything
behind my back
it did lead to a lot of fighting and
insecurities we fought a lot about i'm
gonna say this
you can't argue with your girl when she
gave you her kidney you cheat on her you
better be an obedient little puppy you
better shut your [ __ ] mouth because
the reason why you get to live to some
degree is cause she's inside you
that's foul that's foul but it's not
because you it doesn't guarantee
anything
i i i agree but it's it is yeah i agree
doesn't guarantee anything but if i'm
looking at you
shut your [ __ ] mouth and the trust is
[ __ ] up shut your [ __ ] mouth yeah
i'm actually telling you to get on your
knees and lick her toes which i think
you should do at least once or twice at
the minimum
shut your [ __ ] mouth
her kidneys inside you
it's a tough argument to break you know
what i mean if you got no legs and the
[ __ ] give you one of her legs shut your
[ __ ] mouth you got one and you get on
one knee i don't care if you only got
one knee literally one knee and you hang
your little stump in the air
and you and you propose and you wave it
like you just don't care i'm sorry you
cannot take a kidney from somebody and
then treat that [ __ ] fruitlessly yeah
that's crazy that's it's like a
[ __ ] taking a car but not even a
car that's nothing but like a big old
house no no not even that there's
nothing that's gonna compare to a
[ __ ] kidney bro
you could say a house you could say
nothing is going to compare to that
yeah me not giving him enough trust and
it just felt repetitive it really took a
toll on our relationship one day we were
fighting about
him
resenting me of not being forgiving fast
enough and in the middle of the argument
he wanted to stop and
read the bible together i was like no
can we kind of just talk like regular
people and that's when he just
i imagine that's exactly what he did he
pulled out the bible
when he was in vegas talking next [ __ ]
like you shouldn't cheat on your
girlfriend he's like let's read the
bible
just when he says when it's sunday my
dick is in your mouth
[Music]
hey listen man don't be using the bible
to justify your [ __ ]
don't
don't because you certainly wasn't
reading the bible when you out there and
in sinning well maybe he just tried to
be a good person now
the [ __ ] up shut down and pretty much
said like oh if god wanted us to be
together then he'll bring us back
together in the end and hung up
after he hung up on me he blocked me on
social media and
yeah just completely cut me out i felt
really hurt you shouldn't be hurt
because that was god
that was god and god god has a plan for
you baby girl so don't be hurt don't be
bothered understand that this is just
the next step
this is a new door new chapter that's
god
oh god god i had a plan god want us to
be together
god plan
god plan
hey i took that [ __ ] kidney today
you imagine some kids just out there
like some dashes looking at this kid
like hey man we're supposed to see each
other
deuces [ __ ]
just imagine some dad walking out on
these kids be like hey man god plan if
we're supposed to see each other again
god will bring us my plans
my god
where's your dad i don't know he's with
god's plan he's with drake yeah yeah
god plans
now watch that ladies video ki king d he
was in the background yeah oh my he's
kiki
stupid yeah
i just i can't stand it when people [ __ ]
up they don't mention religion at all
then they they want to take away the
responsibility all of a sudden god comes
into the plan
no no own that
you the individual did that don't be
putting jesus in your [ __ ] that's
you
that's you the whole time he was
watching like yeah this man really i
never heard of that before
i have i never heard nobody pull out the
bible and be like
this is god's will
oh
you
you're not you're not raised christian
go on that's it you i've heard that
what'd you hear
people breaking up that was not the plan
that was not what god wanted i don't
think that we should yeah
they excuse that [ __ ] every bit i've
seen people excuse all their behavior
and then say god god it was it's either
the devil and in god
me what killed me is the fact that he
really pulled out the bible he's like
[ __ ] read
goodbye that he could just you know
throw me out of his life like that i
would work at disneyland five days a
week and it was kind of hard to you know
keep that smile throughout my shift but
i decided to make peace with the
situation
and decided to stop trying to contact
him even after everything has happened i
still don't regret
donating my kidney to him despite the
trauma and the heartbreak that i had to
go through it did lead me to
a better life and that's how i met my
current boyfriend i'm with someone who
really loves me unconditionally be
hilarious if he did was his kidney to
her and then she cheated on him
full circle
full circle i haven't been happier i'm
not mad at him i don't hold any grudges
against him i only wish him well and for
him to live a happy life and that's
because you're a good christian
i don't know i don't believe you want to
say some [ __ ] like that
but you gave him his kidney stop capping
no she can no i think there's some
people there's people like that it can
be like
because it's the same thing that you
told me about people going to prison and
when i was like yo i can't even and you
know you go to prison for a wrong reason
for you know it's not forgiveness
and then you just at some point you like
you accepted your faith like that's
that's what you that's that's what it is
he's white
you know what i mean so that that's
pretty much it so at some point you just
have to forgive for you
some people like that so you gave me
that for the people that went to
like for 25 [ __ ] years in jail i can
imagine that if you're in jail
i can imagine that if you're in jail and
you're in solitary crime with nothing
but your thoughts out here
nah that's me personally yeah
i can see it you know i don't see the
environment but here
to me personally some should do
turn that turn that whole [ __ ]
situation to a jasmine sullivan song
keep his car kiss tires
call his mama a [ __ ] whatever you want
to do
you lost the kidney you earned a right
basically you lost a body part
take one of his parts
basically be toxic yes
yes
in that circumstance a [ __ ] kidney
[ __ ] don't don't be pointing you don't
know what are you kidding me you don't
know where it is it's over there you
don't even know yeah it's right there
you don't even you don't even i know
because i had kidney stones okay yeah i
literally felt like i felt the [ __ ]
pain radiant [ __ ] on the both sides no
left side oh that's why you thought it
was only one
yeah i didn't even know the second one
hey [ __ ] can you get kidney stones on
both sides at the same time yeah
yes one side i thought i was losing my
[ __ ]
rough i thought my [ __ ] was gonna
fall out the way the pain was radiating
bro
you know what it felt like this is the
best way you ever seen sonar in the
submarine that's how the pain
yeah
yeah yeah i want to get into it it's
most painful experience my entire life
that's why you drink a whole lot of
water because that [ __ ] is it's wolf
it really is [ __ ] it [ __ ] hurts
but
did you pass the stone or you got it you
had to get over operated
oh i had to pass it oh my god to pass it
they gave you some
they gave me a lot of stuff i'm solving
they gave me a lot of stuff oh my god
they gave me a lot passing a stone bro
a lot of blood
um
it's like you're pissing wolverine and
he's passing like that string
in your [ __ ] god damn passing the
[ __ ]
no but the stone did
you know
they got out it got out
you know listen
some people want to criticize a woman
saying how dare you give your kidney to
somebody that early and i can understand
that by the end of the day you know i
mean she was doing something that she
thought she was doing right for someone
she loved it some people out there is
just
that's absolute trash
that's [ __ ] up
like that's crazy to me
that's crazy but one does not
exempt the other but yeah that's [ __ ]
i mean on his end maybe he's terrified
of dying and always beyond dialysis and
he took this one he probably shouldn't
have because it's like it was one
opportunity to get it
but at the same time i was like god damn
what are you doing
i just feel like some people are
ungrateful
yeah
ungrateful entitled
but i digress
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below do you guys agree or
disagree want to hear from you